org and clicking on the survey link
our american president's life portrait
series now continues with a look at the
sixth chief executive john quincy adams
earlier this year we broadcast live from
the massachusetts historical society in
boston
but first here's a brief look at the
life and times of john quincy adams
he was a politician and a poet a diarist
and a diplomat
he liked billiards played the flute and
was the first president to have his
picture taken
while in office he took morning swims in
the potomac river
and of the first seven chief executives
he and his father were the only two not
to have owned slaves he was john quincy
adams the nation's sixth president
i never was and never shall be what is
commonly termed a popular man
i'm certainly not intentionally
repulsive in my manners and deportment
but i have no powers of fascination none
of the honey which the profligate
proverb says is the true fly catcher he
was born in quincy massachusetts to the
revolutionary john adams and his wife
abigail
they held high expectations for their
eldest son his father once told him
if you do not rise to the head not only
of your profession but of your country
it will be owing to your own laziness
slovenliness and obstinacy
a child during the american revolution
john quincy was eight when he witnessed
the battle of bunker hill while standing
beside his mother on a nearby hilltop an
exceptionally bright young man
his father on diplomatic missions abroad
after graduating from harvard it took
him just two years he entered public
life as minister to the netherlands
three years later his father was elected
the country's second president
john quincy became a u.s senator and
then minister to russia and britain
before being appointed secretary of
state under james monroe
though an effective diplomat adams soon
became known for his prickly personality
one colleague called him hard as a piece
of granite and cold as a lump of ice
i am a man of reserved cold austere and
forbidding manners my political
adversaries say a gloomy misanthrope
my personal enemies an unsocial savage
adams did have an aloof manner
at dinner parties he seldom bothered
with small talk nor was he interested in
clothes
some say he wore the same hat for 10
years
but he was fastidious about writing
regularly and from age 29 to 49 recorded
something in his diary every single day
he even published a small volume of his
own poetry
adams ran for president in 1824 and won
but only technically
andrew jackson received more popular and
electoral votes but because no candidate
in the four-man election had secured a
majority the decision was thrown to the
house which selected adams
jackson supporters were furious and
those in congress proceeded to thwart
several of adam's proposals as president
adams also endured rocky relations with
his vice president john calhoun who went
on to serve under jackson
of his presidential years adams wrote
i can scarcely conceive a more harassing
wearying teasing condition of existence
adam's first lady was louisa johnson
adams
born in london she remains the only
first lady born outside the united
states
louisa read greek wrote french poetry
and played the harp
but she remained intimidated by the
formidable family into which she had
married
as regards women the adams family are
one in all peculiarly harsh and severe
in their characters
there seems to exist no sympathy no
tenderness for the weakness of the sex
louisa called her memoirs adventures of
a nobody
adam served in washington for one
presidential term from 1825 to 1828
losing his second bid for office to his
arch enemy jackson
dejected adams like his father before
him skipped his successor's inaugural
and returned home to massachusetts
a year later however he was on his way
back to washington after his election to
the u s house of representatives
he served there for 17 years earning the
nickname old man eloquent
during this time he was instrumental in
establishing the smithsonian institution
as well as in winning freedom for a
group of slaves captured aboard the
spanish ship amistad
adams was in the house chamber on
february 23 1848 when just after voting
against a proposal to decorate mexican
war generals he suffered a massive
stroke
five doctors attended him four of them
members of the house
lying on a sofa in the speaker's room he
uttered his last words
this is the end of earth
i am content
he fell into a coma and died two days
later he was eighty
welcome to the sixth
of 41 programs devoted to the american
presidents this year
you're looking at the massachusetts
historical society here in boston which
houses the papers of the second
president of the united states john
adams and his wife abigail as well as
the papers of their son the sixth
president of the united states john
quincy adams and those of his wife
louisa catherine adams the massachusetts
historical society is located right in
the city of boston near fenway park
on boylston
you can see right there our school bus
located outside on this day and we have
at least four people you're going to
meet during the next couple of hours
lynn hudson parsons
who is with the state university of new
york at brockport history professor
and a biographer of john quincy adams
william fowler the director of this
institution the massachusetts historical
society celeste walker who's the
associate editor of the adams papers and
peter byrd will join us from the united
states capitol in statuary hall he is in
the guide service there and we'll talk
about
the relationship of john quincy adams to
the house of representatives where he
served for 17 years
here in the ellis room
is lynn hutson parsons professor
follower of john quincy adams what was
the relationship like between john
quincy adams and his wife louisa
catherine adams
they were married for
more than half a century
it was a
marriage not entirely free from tension
there were some periods of time in which
i suspect they did not have much to say
to one another but it survived obviously
for those 50 years what were his
children like
he had three sons and an infant daughter
who
died in russia after about a year
two out of the three sons were
less than successful
in their careers they died in their late
twenties
they are under enormous pressure i think
from the atoms in general as the
introduction indicated uh
there was always in that generation a
great deal of personal pressure to
succeed to fulfill what they had uh
imagined was their destiny uh for the
nation
and uh two out of the three sons didn't
make it uh the third son charles francis
adams uh did he went on to a
distinguished diplomatic career on his
own uh representing the united states
during the civil war uh in london having
been appointed to that position by
abraham lincoln
and is generally accredited to have been
one of the more outstanding ambassadors
to great britain
along with his father and grandfather
who also had that same position as we
have during this series we want you to
join us by telephone the numbers are
going to be popped up there on the
screen
and you'll be able to join us very very
soon that's 202 624 11 11 if you live in
the eastern and central time zone 202
624 1115 if you live in the mountain and
pacific time zones professor parsons how
long have you followed john quincy adams
about a quarter of a century
my original doctoral dissertation did
not deal directly with the adams's it
dealt more with alexander hamilton
and his posthumous reputation what
historians and politicians did to his uh
his reputation
uh while he's on the ten dollar bill why
there's no uh
hamilton memorial in washington to match
the jefferson memorial and so on but i
gradually realized that a good deal of
the uh the image that people have today
of hamilton
was influenced by the adamses who didn't
like him very much
and i became after i finished the
dissertation i kind of moved into the
the adams's and focused on the uh on the
second atom now celeste walker is going
to show us later on some
boxes in the other room 30 of them
filled with the diaries oh yes john
quincy adams have you read all that uh
no i've not read the whole diary from
front to back i've read large portions
of it
it exists in a 12-volume published form
but that's only i think about two-thirds
of it the remaining third has never been
published that's available on microfilm
for those who want to uh look at it in
most of the major research libraries
we're going to take a telephone call in
just a second what did you think of john
quincy adams yourself
well i
one one can't help but be impressed with
the length of his career this is a
person who knew benjamin franklin
and who died in the house of
representatives in the same room with
abraham lincoln
so you have within his lifetime a good
encapsulation of the history of the
early republic and secondly the wide
range of offices that he held i don't
think any president
in before or since has held the range of
offices including a state legislator
congressman senator
secretary of state
representing the united states to the
netherlands to prussia to russia to
great britain negotiating the end of the
war of 1812 secretary of state
and then and then president and he also
was appointed to the supreme court
although he uh turned that down we can
talk about that a little later
columbia south carolina our first call
for this program go ahead please you're
on with professor parsons uh good
morning nice to speak with you today uh
thank you for doing this special
um i'd like to uh first say to professor
parsons my wife is a suny geneseo
graduate so that's right nearby and we
lived there wonderful until we moved
here into south carolina good to hear it
um i've uh i've studied quite a bit
about john quincy adams and
paul nagle in his book uh made the
comparison
of intellect between john quincy adams
and his wife louisa and he seemed to
think that
she might have actually been superior
and intellect to him now i don't think
so i've read quite a bit of his work
and
i'd like your comments on that and also
maybe compare
his his
intellect with his father
and
i'm kind of curious on on your slant on
uh his writing uh publica in
response to time 1792
man
thanks columbia okay let's take the easy
one first and that's a comparison
between the son and the father i would
say that john adams was a much more
profound thinker than his son
john adams has some claim to be has made
some original contributions to political
theory uh as part of the uh case against
the great britain in the uh in the
american revolution
i don't think you can make that claim
for his son the sons interests however i
think were much broader uh john quincy
adams was interested in literature he
was interested in the theater he was
interested in science he knew uh a lot
about music he was perhaps the leading
authority on the bible uh during uh his
uh uh later years uh so we're we're
contrasting depth with breadth i think
in in that matter with regard to the the
comparison between john quincy adams and
his wife
anytime you deal with the career of a
woman in the 18th or 19th and possibly
even the 20th century you have to
recognize that the social uh constraints
on the development of any practically
any woman's intellect was such that we
really can't answer that question
paul nagle is is quite possibly correct
that potentially uh louisa catherine
adams had the same range of intellect
the same potential that john quincy did
because she lived in a but because she
lived in a society where that was not
allowed to blossom uh we will never know
uh the third item uh the publicola
letters uh which were published in the
early 1790s as a an attempt to refute
thomas payne's uh
defense of the french revolution
those ran i think they're about half a
dozen of them and as you probably know
most people thought that they had been
written by john adams where in fact
they'd been written by his son
and they kind of contributed to the
beginning of the differences between
john adams and thomas jefferson which
would ultimately end uh as you know at
least for the in the 1790s and they're
opposing each other twice for the
presidency once in 1796 and again in
1800
one of the reasons we're doing this is
for education purposes and our
cable in the classroom c-span in the
classroom organization is ready to
enroll you if you are a teacher you can
see on the screen there the telephone
numbers and the website folks are there
at the office to take your call that's
202-626-4858
those of you who want to connect via the
internet at cspan.org slice classroom
there are lesson plans and there are
materials that you can use in the
classroom available to you all free of
charge give our group a call this
morning if you want to and get involved
in all this there's
no money exchange it's a chance for you
to use audio visual and printed
materials from us in the classroom
and we are at the massachusetts
historical society the reason we're here
instead of over at the homes which
aren't that far away from here the adams
mansion in quincy is just 20-25 minutes
away uh we're here because we were there
for the second show with david
mccullough we talked just about john
adams we also have here the
director of this institution bill fowler
is over in the other room and can tell
us a little bit more about what the
what's in this institution mr fowler
good morning brian welcome to the
historical society nice to be here and
you've got things here other than just
adam's material don't you oh we
certainly do
within this building we have something
in excess of 10 million manuscripts
5 000 maps quarter of a million books
broadsides it's an enormous collection
outside the library of congress brian if
you allow me to brag a bit this is the
most incl most important collection of
american history
how long has this building been here
this building has been here exactly 100
years this month
the building was constructed for the
historical society and was opened in
april of 1899.
this however is not our first home or
our only home
the society was founded in 1791 we are
the oldest historical society in the
united states and in fact we are the
oldest historical society in the world
devoted to collecting american
manuscripts i know you taught 26 years
at northeastern university also i got
your phd at notre dame i certainly did i
the first 26 years i spent in the
classroom and enjoyed every minute of it
how long have you been here i've been
here now about 15 months
and if if memory serves me right you've
got something of value in your hand oh i
certainly do
today is a very special day here in
boston it is the 18th of april
some of you some of your viewers will
certainly remember the poem
listen my children and you shall hear
the midnight ride of paul revere was the
18th of april in 75 when hardly a man is
now alive so today is the
224th anniversary of paul revere's ride
our founders in 17 the 1790s and in
particular a man named jeremy belnap was
very concerned to collect the materials
of american history these were men who
had lived through the creation of the
american republic and so belknap went
about like a prowling wolf collecting
manuscripts and material of course in
the 1790s paul revere was still very
much an important citizen of this town
so mr belknap went to mr revere and
asked him if he would write down what
happened on the 18th of april in 1775.
mr revere responded and the document
that you now see on the screen is in
fact in mr revere's own hand and this is
his report
which he gave to jeremy belnap on the
first of january 1798
describing what happened to him
and i'd like to read just a small
portion of that document which may be
quite familiar to many of your viewers
mr revere describes how he had just
returned from a ride to lexington this
was a ride prior to the 18th of april
and he describes what happened when he
came back and here's how he reported it
to jeremy belnap
i returned at night through charlestown
there i agreed with colonel conant and
some other gentlemen that if the british
went out by water we would show two
lanterns in the north church steeple and
if by land won
as a signal for we were apprehensive it
would be difficult to cross the charles
river or get over boston neck and of
course indeed on the evening of the 18th
of april at old north church one if by
land two if by sea
this by the way is the report
that henry wards with longfellow had an
opportunity to see and this is the
report upon which he based his epic poem
in that he wrote in 1863
bill founder let me ask you a couple
quick questions and we're going to let
you go and bring you back later but the
massachusetts historical society is
underwritten by whom the society is a
private society brian and we're
supported by the generosity of our
members and we're also supported by
various foundations and granting
agencies we've been generously supported
by the national endowment for the
humanities as well as the national
historic records publication commission
how much of a budget do you have every
year we have an annual budget of about 2
million dollars we have a full-time
staff of approximately 26 people people
allowed to visit all not only allowed
encouraged in fact it's hard to imagine
that any serious student of american
history would not have to come here at
some point in their work in order to
consult our materials
we are free and open to the public so it
does not cost anything to belong no we
do not charge for using our materials
thanks for joining us
bill fowler we really appreciate your
hospitality and we have a call waiting
in saratoga wyoming go ahead please good
morning brian as a long time resident of
boston and a proud graduate of boston
university i'm glad to see your
your clips from boston this morning and
i have two questions about john quincy
adams
first if i could i'd like to thank you
for getting me a wife indirectly when i
moved to a remote area of the country
and didn't have c-span
i asked a couple people i knew to
help me with petitions to get on the
local cable
company and one of the women came back
so quickly with her petition failed i
asked her how she did it she said she
went to the branch office of the bank
first she asked the branch manager to
sign it then everybody else signed it
and as a consequence we were able to get
on our
get c-span on our cable so i was glad
for that
my two questions this morning
the first is
what is exactly the pronunciation of
john quincy adams name i always
understood that it was quincy
oh boy
it would i think it depends on what
century you're living in i always
understood you pronounce the uh the c in
quincy as more like a z as in quincy
john and adams i assume you is not a
problem but but my understanding you you
took a z instead of a c what's your
second question caller and my second
question my wife says to ask you are you
going to cover in your wonderful
presidential series are you going to
cover
the forgotten president
and
and she says his name is jefferson davis
thanks for c spin
thank you jefferson davis of course is
buried in the same cemetery with john
monroe and john tyler and at some point
along the way we will be talking about
jefferson davis on the telephone is
reverend sheldon bennett who's the
pastor of the first parish church over
in quincy massachusetts where the two
presidents named adams are buried good
morning reverend bennett are you there
yes i am good morning brian i know
you're busy and you've got to preach
this morning and we appreciate your time
for these few minutes tell us why you
have closed the [ __ ] below your church
there where people used to visit the two
presidents and their two wives it's not
something that we wanted to do
for many years we had run a
a volunteer program um
but that became increasingly difficult
to find someone to manage that on a
volunteer basis full time so in 1992 we
had entered into an agreement with the
park service by which they would
provide a ranger but it remained our
responsibility because of issues of
church and state to manage the building
and to provide a staff person
full time for the seven months of the
tourist season
to help us with that the mayor of the
city had pledged his support to raise
you know private contributions and
corporate sponsorships
to help us with our additional uh costs
so it wouldn't be a burden to the church
but that became increasingly uh
difficult in recent years we began
running
a fairly large deficit for us and we
just weren't able financially to
continue it until we're
able to
obtain
sufficient funding so we were just
much against our wishes we just find
ourselves in a position
of not being able to
you know to bear the cost at the present
time how long do you think the [ __ ] will
be close to the public
well i'm hoping
it'll be a very short period of time we
we do have plans we're going to the
to the community to
solicit funds uh to help us with the
costs and if we're successful with that
in the next few weeks hopefully we'll be
uh open shortly but i cannot tell you
right now when whether it's uh four
weeks or six weeks or two months i i
just don't know and how much money do
you have to raise
well uh probably to me to open the
program we'll need to raise about uh 41
000 to
clear up the
deficit and enable us to hire a staff
person
for the season
and if someone wants to get involved in
this where do they contact you
they can contact us here at united first
parish church
1306 hancock street
in quincy 02169 or to call our church
office area 617-773-1290
we have a separate
account for the public visitor program
that's called church of the president's
visitor program
is the church open for people to visit
oh yes we're open for our regular
sunday worship services and uh
other events from time to time it's just
that we're not able to be open seven
days a week um on the on the full
schedule from april through november uh
at the present time
reverend sheldon bennett pastor of the
first uh parish church in quincy thank
you very much for joining us this
morning well you're very welcome and for
our guest here on the set in the ellis
hall of the massachusetts historical
society as we feature a look at john
quincy adams our sixth president we go
next to
a call from it was on the screen there a
moment shorewood
illinois good morning go ahead please
yeah good morning uh c-span is wonderful
brian uh my question for the professor
has to do with uh
jimmy carter and ronald reagan it has
always struck me that the political
dynamics
surrounding the quincy adams
administration and the reagan
administration were very similar to some
of the political dynamics surrounding
the
cart the
the jimmy carter administration and the
ronald reagan administration i wonder if
he could comment on that and also
perhaps a little bit on
on the character of john quincy adams uh
not to be palsied by the wills of our
constituents
his interest in astronomy and so on he
seems to me to have been a very
visionary president
yes i i assume the parallel that you
have in mind is that uh jimmy carter was
limited to one term
and was like john quincy adams
unsuccessful uh in his quest for a
re-election and was succeeded by an
immensely popular and charismatic
individual
much along the lines of andrew jackson
allowing of course for the difference in
time
yes that parallel has has occurred to me
and it also
uh is similar to the difference of the
relationship between john adams and
thomas jefferson earlier in which again
the first adams was denied reelection
and succeeded by a more popular
individual and of course jqa himself
i'm working on a on an essay which i
hope to complete sometime
that
discusses that
adams jefferson and adams jackson uh
relationship because the the parallel
goes beyond that in as you probably know
with adams and jefferson they were good
friends uh for a long time went their
separate ways ran against one another
and then
about 10 years after adams's defeat were
reconciled through the males and we have
that very rich correspondence between
john adams and thomas jefferson between
1812 and 1826.
likewise john quincy adams and andrew
jackson were
almost uh part of a mutual admiration
society prior to their
to adams's first candidacy in fact at
one point john quincy adams was the only
member of president monroe's cabinet to
support andrew jackson's somewhat
aggressive attack on florida in which he
invaded a spanish fort executed a number
of indians and hanged two englishmen
something of an international uh scandal
was about to break out but john quincy
adams was one of the few people that
defended jackson rightly or wrongly for
what he had done
then when they became rivals they went
their separate ways just as the father
had with thomas jefferson
but they are the parallel stops because
you'll recall that john quincy adams
came back to congress
and spent the rest of his career more or
less in opposition to the jacksonian
democrats and the relationship between
the two deteriorated rapidly
and was not friendly at all toward the
end he was in the united states senate
for how long uh congress uh the house of
representatives no senate uh
adams was in the senate from 1804 to
1818 three to 18 seven and who put him
there he was elected by the
massachusetts legislature as senators
were in those days he was the president
for how long he was president for four
years and he was in the house of
representatives for 14 years let's go to
albuquerque new mexico next go ahead
please you're on with len parsons yes
good morning um in the movie amistad
the attorneys for the slaves sought the
council of john quincy adams could you
comment on that if that was historically
accurate and exactly what role that john
quincy adams played in that incident
thank you very much a mild correction
that they were not slaves if they were
slaves there would have been no case
they were africans who the courts
determined had been kidnapped and
therefore were returned to africa yes
that is accurate uh the the abolition
attorneys for the africans of the
amistad did uh
recruit on quincy adams he did plead
their case before the supreme court
along with mr baldwin of connecticut as
you saw in the film
i thought the character that sir anthony
hopkins created for john quincy adams
was extremely uh accurate as far as the
personality and his curmudgeonly
aspects there
the actual words and some of the scenes
there we would have to say the directors
and the scriptwriters uh took a great
deal of advantage of what we'll have to
call poetic license how sick was john
quincy adams in his life
i don't think he was any more uh in ill
health for anyone given that age he was
our first presidential jogger he was the
first one to uh well let me begin by
saying the adams's of that generation
father and said had a tendency to put on
weight and they were aware of that and
so they did exercise at least john
quincy adams
and he could be seen
in in the
secretary of state and as president uh
jogging around washington he uh had a uh
how old is he in that picture there and
that one he's 72. that was taken uh in
his old age i don't think he was jogging
anymore at that point but when he was 59
years old he wrote in his diary that he
could make it from the white house to
the capitol and back in an hour flat
which most presidents i don't think can
do today we're going to meet celeste
walker in a few moments but first we
have a call from leroy new york go ahead
please hi dr parsons this is chris from
your early republic class good morning
thank you
are you in are you in dr parsons class
now yes i am yeah first of all i want to
know is this going to be on the exam
it could be chris it could be
you know me well enough that i don't i
don't discount anything
it's got to be in a six-page paper too
my question is
john quincy adams opposition to indian
removal was that on
religious moral grounds or was that just
strictly
in opposition to anything
that jackson favored
it didn't uh it didn't hurt that it was
in opposition to anything that jackson
did
but as you as you know i have become
convinced that as adams who started out
with a fairly jacksonian position uh on
indians namely that they had no rights
that white people were entitled to
respect
uh and that the europeans had a better
claim to the soil because they used it
more efficiently than the allegedly
hunting and nomad uh habits of of
indians uh toward the end of his life
and i think next to his uh anti-slavery
positions in the 1830s and 1840s he
became convinced that the american
people were committing a grave injustice
against the against the indians on moral
grounds as well as simple
equity and decency and so he took the
position that you uh that you're well
aware of not far from here if you want
to visit these
uh major historical spots is they are
the birthplaces of both john quincy
adams and john adams we showed that in
our second program we have it on
videotape now over in quincy
massachusetts it used to be called
braintree we'll show you those homes
here i hope in just a moment uh that's
and then we're let's just take a call
that's there they are on your screen
let's go to eureka california next go
ahead please you're on the air good
morning brian thank you for this series
i really appreciate it i was calling
regarding john quincy adams and how
pertinent
some of his advice as secretary of the
state
177 years ago in that he cautioned that
by intervention in the balkans america
would involve herself beyond the power
of extraction in all wars of interest
and intrigue of individual advice
avarice envy and ambition which assume
the colors and usurps the standards of
freedom i thought this was quite
pertinent
and this is from the washington times
the february first through the 7th
national weekly edition i would like a
comment from the professor thank you
yes that's taken from probably the most
important
oration that john quincy adams ever
delivered on july 4th 1821 and uh the
the passage before that
you may recall he says america does not
go forth uh in search of monsters to
destroy
and every time the united states has
become involved in a war uh or military
action in some other continent
you can count on those words being
being quoted
if you're asking me what john quincy
adams attitude would be toward current
events in the balkans i haven't a clue
but uh certainly within the context of
the 1820s given the isolation that the
united states uh enjoyed or endured at
that point given the uh the the distance
in terms of of communication
there was no way in which john quincy
adams or i think any other president of
that generation
would countenance
involvement in a european war in the
20th century beginning with woodrow
wilson
things changed and whether john quincy
adams would have said in 1917 we are now
a major power we now have a capability
of dealing with these things and what i
said in 1821 is no longer valid in 1917
or 1941 or 1950 or 1965 or 1999 i have
no idea our guest professor parsons got
his masters from johns hopkins
university in 1964 and then he got a phd
in history in 67 from the same
university any relationship between your
name lynn hudson parsons and your
hometown of lynn massachusetts
no i was named after my grandfather
who was in fact active in public affairs
for a long time many years ago and the
interest that i have in public affairs
like i sometimes subscribe to him but
that uh i don't think they named the
town after him either i think that's a
coincidence any relationship between
your
wife anne heruska parsons and roman
herroska the former senator from
nebraska yes she is his uh niece is he
still alive yes he is how old a man is
he uh is a bit younger than strong
thurman uh we uh had anything
we had lunch a couple three years ago uh
we come from a different political
persuasion but he's always been very
kind where does he live he lives in
omaha in nebraska covington louisiana
for our guests go ahead please
yes um in reference to john quincy adams
and also andrew jackson that time period
from me being in louisiana and of course
the battle of new orleans in 1814
there's still a running debate for a lot
of us down here historically as to
whether or not if the british would have
defeated
the u.s troops in that battle even
though a treaty was signed uh would the
british continue to take over aggressive
action and control the mississippi which
would control the western developing
states
such that we possibly would to this day
and time would be with a british accent
as we speak here but could you just
respond to that and i'll listen to your
answer thank you
well there were the british accents
instead of a cajun accent uh
uh yes that that that has always been
pointed out and i again there's no way
that can be resolved uh it's often been
said that had there been a transatlantic
cable back in 1815 uh with the news of
the end of the war being transmitted to
the united states overnight that there
would have been no battle and
consequently no andrew jackson to uh
revere in later generations but the the
point is is a valid one that uh if the
british had one it's not clear that that
treaty that adams had negotiated would
have
required them to give up uh the capture
of one of the major american cities at
the time do you have any idea what he
would have john quincy adams would have
sounded like
uh vaguely he was not in spite of uh the
fact that he was referred to as old man
eloquent which i think is a quotation
from a poem by milton
he was not a great orator in the daniel
webster uh sense or even in the sense
that his father was a great order the
accounts that i have read suggest that
he had a rather uh high-pitched
uh occasionally grating voice
particularly if you didn't agree with
what he was saying how tall was he he
was five seven five eight
and how much time did he spend at the
adams house over in quincy
he spent uh most of his life there
from the time when john adams died in
july 4th 1826 uh he spent his summers
there most of the time and then of
course winters uh in washington at four
and a half f street uh which was his
house at that time who were his best
friends
his best friends um
his wife i think possibly uh his his um
we need to talk about her
uh he the the everett brothers uh edward
everett uh best known for being the
other uh speaker at gettysburg the hour
and 59 minute speech yes right
he was very close to edward and his uh
older brother
alexander everett and the diary
indicates
considerable
conversations and correspondence with
them but
you put your finger on a question i
never really have thought about before i
don't think he had
close friends he was not that kind of
person he had people respected him
people admired him uh but there weren't
too many people that loved him and we're
going to find out this later firsthand
but where did he die
he died
in the
house of representatives chamber
which is now statuary hall in washington
uh there is a disc on the floor there
that marks the spot and then he actually
he was stricken there and carried into
the next room and died there two years
uh two two days later and of course for
our audience anybody ever visited the
capitol and got on the tour you remember
the whisper room where they
stand on other sides of the room you can
hear people whispering that's that's
where we're gonna go later newburyport
massachusetts you'll meet celeste walker
right after this call go ahead please
yes good morning brian good morning and
uh i'm from new report and uh i have uh
found in the local library an abridged
version of the diary of john quincy
adams edited by
alan nevins
and i was looking through it yesterday
and there was a
in the chronology of his life as a note
that after he graduated from harvard
that he studied law in new report with
a gentleman named theophilus parsons who
later became chief justice of
massachusetts and i was wondering if
your guest could
comment on that period of his of his
early life
i thought you were going to ask if i was
related to theophilus parsons and the
answer to that is i'm not sure
uh first of all what you want to do is
get the not the alan nevins
edition of the john quincy adams diary
but the first two volumes of the diary
which were published by the
massachusetts historical society at some
point in the 1980s because they go into
great detail or the diary goes into
great detail about john quincy adams
life in newberry report his
relationships with the young women of
newburyport and his studying law yes
with the theophilus parsons who was the
next to john adams himself i suppose the
outstanding legal
authority in massachusetts in those days
as you know you didn't go to law school
it was more like an apprentice
relationship and you spent maybe a year
or two in the office of a well-known
attorney who after the end of that
period would present you before the
court and certify that you knew what you
were doing and the practice law from
that how old was john quinzianus when he
died he was
in his 81st year
and when do you think he was the
happiest
i think he was
i think he was the happiest
on the floor of the house of
representatives
presenting petitions on behalf of the
anti-slavery cause and being squelched
over and over again by the uh by the
pro-slavery uh people and their northern
allies did he ever own slaves no he did
not
celeste walker is the associate editor
of the adams papers she is here
at the massachusetts historical society
today and she's going to tell us all
about why she is so interested in this
subject good morning good morning brian
as you can see i'm surrounded by volumes
of the diary here
john quincy adams kept his diary for
over 65 years
he
kept it unbroken entries
for 26 years that means that he wrote in
the diary every single day
now i have here in front of me
the first volume of his diary
here's the title page
it says a journal
a journal by me
jqa
what year
1779 he was 12 years old
he was about ready to leave for europe
for the second time
with his father
and
this booklet next to it
shows
the drawings of two ships as you can see
the frightful
and the horrid uh
john quincy adams was a little boy a lot
of people don't
think of him that way but
he started out young and you can see
where he had his imagination now
this is the actual
paper and pen and it's this is the
actual diary here is the first entry and
right around you in those boxes are the
entire
works absolutely how and have you read
all those
no
how much of that have you read well i'm
editing right now uh volumes three and
four of the diary so we're very much
into that uh
and as uh professor parsons we dip into
the diary as we need to could you just
open up one of them just to show
everybody how they're stored and and we
can go back to it later whatever you
want to do just
sure are these who makes these boxes by
the way
these boxes were made
to hold the diaries
uh they were made by the historical
society right here
not right here they were measured and
made outside i think they came from
scotland
and that
who binds them like what you what this
is the original binding
did he do it himself i mean did he have
it done one back then i think he did
this is a
kind of vellum it says diary on it
it has the dates stamped
1795
and if i open it up
you can see
tiny little
handwriting handwriting and perfectly
straight
mostly
very readable always the same
very few crossouts
does the uh what what kind of language
what kind of you know
how well was it written
it was
it's very readable the character of the
diary is very much so that
he will discuss personal things but he
does not really discuss
what
conversation went into making the
personal
decisions and you say he did it every
day for at least 26 years 26 years not a
day missing and then a total of how many
days do you think over his whole life
did he write a diary
well the diary spans 68 years i think
it's probably in the 50-year enough
entries for
50 to 60 years stay there obviously
we'll come right back we got a call
waiting and inkster michigan go ahead
please you're on the air hello angster
good morning all how are you doing today
good thanks for joining us oh thank you
i had a quick question concerning uh
john quincy adams religious beliefs and
those of his peers i'm told that the
unitarian church and the freemasons had
quite a influence over the early period
of our country
thanks for the call
john quincy adams did not join a church
until after his father's death
in 1826 when he joined the first parish
church in quincy that we just saw the
film clips of it which was at the time
and still is a unitarian church and
therefore he is one of the half dozen or
so presidents that the unitarians
will claim
but that did not mean that he was
indifferent to religion because his
diary as celeste could tell you
contains almost every sunday
the record of the church service that he
attended sometimes he attended two and
an analysis of the sermon whether he
agreed with it or not or so on uh so he
was very much uh interested in religion
uh he uh became uh in in the in his
latter years in the in the in his
seventies he was president for a long
time of the american bible society he
was perhaps the most learned of all our
presidents uh on the bible and its
teachings and its various
interpretations i would have to describe
him as a something of a conservative
unitarian because he uh he took the
bible quite seriously he didn't
treat it as a fundamental as a
fundamentalist would but he was inspired
by it he was familiar with it
accepted the probability of the divinity
of jesus he believed in an afterlife
these are things that unitarians today
probably would have some reservations
about scaffolding you see on the screen
from the church is where the church is
under repair and you saw pew 54 was that
the pew do i remember the number correct
that john adams used to sit in that
that's my understanding yes walnut creek
california you're next go ahead please
thank you i'm enjoying the show i'm
proud to say i grew up in quincy
massachusetts
and i did my high school study on the
friendship between john adams and
jefferson and
actually evolved my lifelong stance that
life is long because they did mend their
differences and they think they both
died on the same day yes they did the
father
um but um does anybody know i remember
it as being braintree and we were told
uh babies were brained on those trees
and that's where the name came from and
did they change the name to quincy
because of the adams family or which
came first
the name first of all i don't think
that's the accurate the origin of the
term i think it comes from a town in in
london i'm sorry in england with that
same name it was changed uh actually
brain street is still there it's the
north parish of braintree that was
changed to quincy probably in
recognition of
the first john quincy who was john
quincy adam's grandfather and the long
role that he had played well the quincy
family and generally in general uh
played in the in massachusetts affairs
uh so it was just kind of a legal change
from that north parish that became now
the town of quincy as opposed to
braintree which remained that way for
the rest of the rest of the area in the
other room from where we are in ellis
hall is celeste walker who is pure
massachusetts she was born in marlboro
massachusetts she went to school at
newton massachusetts the newton college
of the sacred heart and um
i i asked you earlier and we didn't get
to it but how did you start
when did you first get interested in
being an editor of the adams papers well
i was very fortunate the summer after i
graduated from college
the adams papers was looking for an
editorial assistant and they had
an editorial assistant at the time who
had graduated from newton college so i
heard about the opening and i came in
and i was fortunate enough to get the
job and start working with lyman
butterfield who was the first
editor-in-chief of the adams papers now
someone comes to the library here and we
learned from
bill earlier that you can come here it
doesn't cost you any money you can use
this place can you put your hands on
those diaries that are behind you
if you come to read the adam's papers
you'll see them on microphone uh part of
this is for preservation part of this is
for security if there's trouble reading
the volumes of course we help people out
with the originals you want to show us
something else that you have there on
the table
yes i i have here and this is about
going back to john quincy adams diary
where it looked like as a mature man and
this is when he heard about the news of
his mother's death
his mother had been very sick in 1818
and he had spent about six weeks
at home in the fall
now he was negotiating a very important
treaty he had to get back to washington
he heard about her death a couple days
after she died
and he writes in his diary the feelings
his father had for his mother and his
admiration of his mother
and he starts here
she had been 54 years the delight of my
father's heart
the sweetener of all his toils
the comforter of all his sorrows
the sharer and heightener of all his
joys
and the last time he saw his father
he said
he told him and this is john adams
telling john quincy adams
that
in all the vicissitudes of his fortunes
through all the good report and evil
report of the world
in all his struggles and in all his
sorrows the affectionate participation
and cheering encouragement of his wife
had been his never failing support
without which he was sure he could never
have lived through them now she died in
1818 and he died in 1826 to either one
of you know what uh john quincy adams
uh
life was like
after his mother died or even john adams
who lives i mean i i john quincy adams
didn't die till many years later but
abigail adams husband lived another
eight years it was his life like without
her his his house was filled with um
children his
son thomas wilston adams who had seven
children
and thomas boyleston adams's wife lived
with john adams
as well i think
another
granddaughter
and
her children her two daughters were
living in the house so there were quite
a few people in the house which at that
time wasn't as big as it is now if
you've just joined us we are in uh our
sixth of 41 programs devoted to the 41
men who are president of the united
states it goes on throughout the rest of
the year all of these programs are
repeated every friday night east coast
time at eight o'clock for those of you
who can't watch them live the live
programs are done today is the only one
we do on a sunday they're done on
mondays and fridays usually
and we have an education department that
is ready to help you if you're a teacher
use these materials in your classroom
we'll give you a telephone number as you
can see on the screen 202-626-4858
and the website cspan.org classroom
those two addresses and phone numbers
will get you to our education department
joanne wheeler and her team are there to
take your calls this morning if you're
watching this live we'll send you
materials enroll you and c-span the
classroom all at no charge professor
parsons you want to make this point just
to point out that the addams mansion
will be open tomorrow on patriots day uh
to receive its usual onslaught of
visitors at this time probably more in
view of this program so if you're
watching it live it will be april i'm i
haven't got the date in front of 19th
april 19th and we go to bustai new york
next go ahead please on your screen by
the way is the home where both john
adams and his son john quincy adams live
and many others in the family go ahead
please morning brian and professor it's
a pleasure speaking with you this
morning welcome pleasure enjoyed your
series very much brian
i am a
i am a mason i am the master of the
justice robert h jackson lodge research
in western new york and i have a book
written by john quincy adams
freemasonry by john quincy adams
and i was wondering
what the
professor whether he'd read that book or
or not and what his opinion of uh uh
john quincy adams rabid uh anti-masonic
stand was right and i have another
question
when he's done if if possible go ahead
yeah i have not read it but i am
familiar with it as you know uh in
my part of the country now western new
york state they're uh erupted in the
late 1820s uh a furious uh campaign
against the masonic order on a variety
of charges having to do with being a
secret society and and undermining the
allegedly undermining the principles of
republican government
and john quincy adams uh for reasons
that are not entirely clear to me
uh latched on to that and for the next
five or six years became part of and a
supporter of the anti-mason party the
anti-masonry movement movement
and even i think contemplated and would
have accepted a presidential nomination
in 1832 from the anti-masonic party had
come his way it did not as you know
he ran for governor of massachusetts in
1833 on a anti-masonic ticket
and came in i believe second in that
particular race
where his animus against the masons
comes from i'm not sure other than that
he accepted the argument which you know
was
prevalent in many parts of the country
particularly in the north that as a
secret organization
it was incompatible uh with true
republican as they would have said in
those days government follow-up question
sir
the
follow-up question is uh president grant
is the
god-given name was uh
hiram ulysses grant and uh the story
goes that his name had to be changed to
ulysses
for him to gain admission into west
point and that john quincy adams being
in congress at the time of his
appointment was the reason for that name
change and i wonder if the professor
could comment on that that's i i knew
about the name change but i did not know
about the connection with jq adams i'll
have to check into that thank you for
bringing it to my attention celeste
walker from reading the diaries of john
quincy adams what kind of a person comes
through just from the diaries
just from the diaries
i think what you see from the diaries is
how much he was alone
how much he wasn't at home
he
left home
first time at the age of nine
he was in europe went back at age 12.
he spent a lot of time without his
mother his sister
when his family reunited in france he
was
came back here to go to school
and then as they were talking before he
was in newburyport so i don't think john
quincy adams ever
had the hometown
ever had the feeling that there was one
spot where he
truly belonged where the people
were
his friends the hatchet pete california
next go ahead please yes this is john
claussen
uh
i'd like to ask a question
of celeste walker but first i'd like to
thank brian very very much
for this program it's wonderful i'm 89
renewing my studies
even for using a computer
but i want to ask the last walker
if
she has a record in his if he recorded
his feeling while he was president he
knew there was going to be a civil war
he was very certain
and when did he express himself that i
know afterwards in the 11 years in the
house of representatives he never quit
talking about abolition my interest is
because i'm a director and john brown
the abolitionist
and many of the family are buried here
in pasadena and my uncle is buried up on
the side of brown mountain
above the jet propulsion laboratory in
case people don't know that generally
where where are you
john brown is buried there no no your
uncle is where's john my great uncle
owen brown
harpers ferry virginia
uh there when uh during the problems
with uh
the raid on harper's ferry
thanks for calling okay thanks we're
gonna let celeste walker inside go ahead
please
i think what you see in the diary is he
does know that
well he fears there may be a civil war
he doesn't think the country and here's
someone who was living before the
country was really founded
he doesn't think that the country can
withstand something like this and so
this is the problem how do you find a
solution
to slavery without splitting the country
apart so i think it was probably
even though
he may have thought it was inevitable it
was his hope that something could happen
so this would not happen we're going to
meet peter burt in just a second who's
in the united states capitol and we'll
talk to him about
statuary hall where the house of
representatives used to meet professor
persons comment on the last question
at the time of the missouri debates in
1820 and 1821
uh this was when he was secretary of
state uh john quincy adams followed them
very closely i think he went over to the
senate in the house chamber to watch
and he said when he came back after one
of the sessions he said this is
the title page to a tragic volume so he
sensed that there was this could have no
happy outcome even even before he became
president hartford connecticut you're
next good morning brian thank you for
c-span i'm sorry i have laryngitis this
morning
i'm curious about the relationship
between adam's john quincy adams's
personality and the fact that he got
elected through so many things
was campaigning different did people
make their decisions based on different
criteria i wonder what the professor
might have to offer about that thank you
all right thanks but let me go back to
the actual statistics on when he was
elected president
what did he you know break it in 1924
yeah
i've forgotten the exact uh numbers but
uh andrew jackson uh got more popular
votes than he did
by several percentage points like two or
three ps yeah it was it was it was uh
not exactly a landslide but it was it
was persuasive got more electoral votes
and got more electoral votes but the
constitution then and now as a matter of
fact states that you become president
only if you have a majority of the
electoral votes and that's what threw it
into the house of representatives
whereas it turned out john quincy adams
had more friends than andrew jackson did
uh and put him in the presidency
uh i mean if the fourth on that list was
henry clay who went on to be secretary
of state for john quincy right
was it the rule there's a there's an
anecdote there too but the the rule at
that time was the top three
uh or you choose from and henry clay was
fourth so he didn't make it uh into the
uh into the pool if he had made it he
conceivably would have been elected
president over all of the others but the
other two candidates were william
crawford who was ill
and incapacitated having suffered a mild
cerebral hemorrhage and andrew jackson
and henry clay although he could not be
president as speaker of the house
had a good deal of influence over how
the house representative voted and
tipped the balance toward
john quincy adams in what became known
ever afterwards as the corrupt bargain
how many electoral votes did
john quincy adams get when he ran in
1828 i don't regret i don't recall the
account but there was uh
that was uh
a clear-cut victory for jackson there
was no putting that in the house of
representatives there wasn't any
question that the public did not want to
serve jackson got about 54 of the
popular vote i've forgotten the
electoral account and when he went in
back to our caller's question but when
he won the united states senate uh
situation how difficult was that for him
to win this the legislature vote here um
this would have been back in 183184 that
uh was not something that the popular
masses had any say and it was the
legislature that elected him but the the
caller makes a good point in that
adams did not have a he he was an
introverted
uh i think probably would call him a
type a personality today he was very
driven he was not he was uncomfortable
in crowds he would not be considered
seriously as a presidential candidate
today at all because he really didn't
campaign in those days his model his his
role model was not his father but george
washington who did not campaign for
office either and it always was his
regret i think that the office did not
come to him the way it had come to
george washington he didn't realize of
course there could only be one george
washington if you've just joined us
we're at the massachusetts historical
society headquarters in boston
massachusetts on boylston street
picture on your screen right there our
camera outside our bus sits alongside
massachusetts historical society we're
not very far
away from fenway park those of you who
are sports fans and not too far away
from the prudential center which is
right down that street
those of you familiar with this area we
have
peter byrd who is united states capital
guide service tour guide with us this
morning there's a picture of the capitol
he's on the other side of that in
statuary hall hello peter byrd good
morning brian how are you doing i'm good
how are you this morning very well
where are you
right now i'm in national statuary hall
which is in the original south wing of
the capital just to the south side of
the great rotunda under the dome we
might as well go right to it because i
know you've told the story hundreds of
thousands of times what's the whisper
story
the whisper story uh which i will
preface by saying is an apocryphal folk
story
uh concerns the fact that the acoustics
of the room are are influenced by the
unusual shape of the ceiling perhaps the
cameraman could pan and look up at the
ceiling just to show the
the unusual shape there it allows for
the sound to bounce off the floor on one
side of the room reflect off the ceiling
and then over to the other side
interestingly when the house actually
met here there was a wooden floor and a
wooden ceiling in place
and the whisper actually worked through
the whole room not just from the few
spots as we think of it today
most important was putting up a cast
steel ceiling right at the turn of the
last century for fire proofing reasons
that left this uh whisper just working
in a few spots and of course
what makes it so famous for everyone is
the fact that one of those spots was
where john quincy adams desk was located
during at least some of those 17 years
that he served here in the house
where in that room did he collapse
he collapsed at his desk which from here
i'm gonna point over to the other side
of the room
um
there's
it's out in a space that has only a
plate on the floor from here we wouldn't
be able to see well in fact there's a
lady walking over there let's she's
standing on the spot now how about that
so the lady there with the green tag is
standing on the spot where adam's desk
was and that was the point where he
collapsed right at his desk there where
did they take him after that uh from
there they carried him and we can point
over this way now there's a door over to
the side here that at the time was the
entrance
into the speaker's office
let me just tell our audience that the
desk was on the screen uh just a few
moments ago and that's located over at
the stone library next to the adams
mansion in quincy and on our screen
right now is near the door where he was
taken go ahead with your story i'm sorry
that's fine uh the uh
the door there again goes right in into
a little hallway that goes back to to
where the speaker's formal space was and
there was a couch in there adams was
placed on the couch and uh died two days
later
interestingly the
his
stroke was on the day before
washington's birthday on february 21st
and
he was in his coma throughout
washington's birthday and then died on
the the 23rd
the entire time he served in the house
was how many years 17 1831 to 1848. how
much of it was in that room oh that was
the entire time here what was congress
like then
could you be more specific what was con
well in that era what kind of an
atmosphere was it compared to what we
see today how big was it how many
members were there i see uh well
compared to today significantly less
until early in the 20th century after
each census as the the population
increased they simply increased the
number of members for the house of
representatives
when people come on a tour today there
how many of them know anything about
john quincy adams
the thing that we find that people know
about him
interestingly is that they're expecting
to to play with the whisper spot that we
were just talking about
most people know that he was the sixth
president of the united states
most people know his father john adams
had been president as well i don't find
that too many folks really know the
details of his time as a member of the
house
uh until the amistad movie came out the
other year people were totally
unfamiliar with with his work arguing
that case
and in terms of his time in the senate
or as an ambassador that that's pretty
unknown as well
stay where you are just a moment if you
would i need to take a call here from
san diego california joining us this
morning go ahead please
you know it's interesting that i had met
somebody out here there that
was had been married to
one of john adams great great great
grandson and he had been killed in world
war world war ii
and i was wondering if your uh author
had any contact with any of
uh that
lying or that relative
let me start with celeste walker to ask
her if the many of the relatives come by
here at the massachusetts historical
society well actually we get quite a few
inquiries um for geneal genealogy the
first henry adams that came to this
country had seven sons
and so john adams and john quincy adams
are descended from this henry adams so
there are many cousins many collateral
relatives and the adams family
themselves and the presidential line is
quite large peter byrd do you ever meet
any ancestors
it's interesting because over the years
i have met a number of folks who are
related to folks either in the statuary
in the building or famous members of the
house or senate but i can't think of
anyone off the cuff related to adams how
did you get into this business by the
way of being a tour guide there at
the capitol well i i studied history at
university of north carolina um so i
grew up in a historically minded family
i had uh
gosh i had seven ancestors who came on
the mayflower one of my
fifth great grandfathers died at the
battle of saratoga in the revolution
someday i'll be buried 150 yards from
two of the signers of the declaration of
independence in our family plot
so history was in the family and
after college i always thought it'd be
fun to be a tour guide and and it gives
me a chance to teach people to do
research to to be in the big league so
to speak where so much of the history
has happened i have the best classroom
in the world for teaching visitors
peter byrd thank you very much for
joining us this morning
professor parsons you were going to say
something about the word about the the
death of john quincy adams uh in in 1848
after the ceremonies which were held in
the capitol
his body was taken back to quincy by
train
uh stopping at uh most of the major
cities along the east coast
baltimore philadelphia new york
springfield boston and so forth and that
was the first time that that had ever
been done
it was also what i've called a media
event in that it took place in 1848 and
by that time most of the major cities on
the on the east coast were connected by
telegraph so whereas if that had
happened say five years before it would
have taken two or three days maybe a
week for the news to reach boston
um this time it only took an hour or so
for the whole east coast to know that
john quincy adams had passed on and that
meant it was possible to organize a
funeral procession
by rail uh all the way from washington
to boston that's the first time that
that that
that that had ever happened our next
live
telecast of a president will be stop
number seven with andrew jackson at the
hermitage right outside of nashville
it's about 12 miles outside the the uh
the city and it's beyond april the 26th
at 9 00 a.m when we do it live of course
it's repeated every friday night houston
texas our next call go ahead please
you're on the air
all right um
which um which president
was tyler was he the first second third
fourth
seven or eight
which one
who john tyler
tyler
tyler
how old are you
seven
seven years old
do we get a prize if we answer it
correctly
i think he was the 10th president
do you know that caller
houston
what is your name alicia
alicia
why are you watching this this morning
where's my mom
and you are you studying the presidents
yes
who's your favorite president
um tyler
why
because um
i don't know
that's a good answer thank you for
joining us let's go to quincy
massachusetts next go ahead please
yes brian i have two quick questions for
the professor i live in the section of
quincy called house neck and um john
quincy adams was the third commodore of
a yacht club quincy yacht club from 1880
to 1881 down here another question is
the connection with the quincy public
schools i believe at one time the public
school system turned over some minutes
of a school committee meeting to the
quincy historical society and i believe
either john quincy or his father had
something to do with that thank you
the john quincy adams that was the
commodore of the yacht club in the 1880s
of course uh i think was a grandson
of uh of the president john quincy adams
um
and yes the the the public school system
in quincy i think got a
strong boost i think it was from john
adams not from john quincy adams in the
uh in the uh dedication and the donation
that that you refer they they uh were
very strong supporters of public
education as indeed i think we're most
of the new england culture at that time
and in so doing so they were quite
typical
celeste walker in those diaries uh
how much of the trips that he took from
what was it was 14 years old when he was
in russia
how much of that's in the diaries
he
his first trip to russia was
probably not a happy time for him
he was with francis dana who was trying
to
establish diplomatic relations with
between russia and the united states and
so they were not part of any real circle
he
it's very funny every morning he records
in his diary what the temperature was
and then you come to one day and he says
my thermometer is broken
we don't get the temperature anymore but
it's the same thing he walks he talks to
a few americans uh but it's it's kind of
a boring time for him
nothing like the second time when do you
see the diary really getting interesting
i think you get
his harvard years are very interesting
as a young man he has very full entries
over about two years
he at one point writes a sketch of each
one of his classmates and and talks
about them and where they're from and
what they like to do and uh how he
thinks they are as a person
one in fact he annotated later saying
that he was wrong on one point
by the way if you've just joined us
right behind celeste walker's
head are the uh john quincy adams
diaries in those boxes back there what
else is on the show we always callers
want to know and if we could we might
look around this entire room at some
point so they can see what is the room
that
you're sitting in uh this room is called
the sultan stall room it's uh next to
the room you're in ellis hall and this
is the reading room uh
this is the catalog room if you're
coming to the massachusetts historical
society you would start and you would
look in the catalogs over here there are
book catalogs manuscript catalogs to
find what things you wanted to consult
while you were here
the
books around me are the reference book
collection
they are the books most commonly asked
for and people can come here and take
them off the shelf and use them at this
very table where i'm sitting seattle
washington next call go ahead please
seattle you're on the air
yes good morning
can you hear me we can
50 years ago i did a dissertation on
jefferson davis the president of the
confederacy
caller gonna have to ask you to turn
your television set volume down so that
we can not get the feedback but then go
ahead
in his first
appearance in the house of
representatives
in 1846 or 48
jefferson davis was observed by john
quincy adams then in his last years as a
member of congress
and the story goes that adams recorded
in his diary
of jefferson davis quote that young man
will make his mark
i'm wondering if there's anything
further regarding
adams's opinions or knowledge of
jefferson davis in the few years that
they overlapped
and i just
i'm not i'm not aware of any uh i am
aware of the fact that uh as you
probably know
john quincy adams had a long-term
relationship with john c calhoun
whom he admired greatly for his
intellect
his range of background of course
calhoun was educated in yale university
which is almost as good as being
educated at harvard for adams but an
enormous respect for his intellect he uh
increasingly found himself at odds with
calhoun on a range of political issues
as i'm sure you know and that would have
been the case with jefferson davis but i
i was unaware that the careers
overlapped and it's quite possible that
he could have made that observation by
the way this series will go on
throughout the rest of the year it
doesn't really end until december the
20th with bill clinton 41 presidents 42
presidencies grover cleveland had an
interrupted
term where he was defeated by benjamin
harrison and uh yes professor could i
say something about the diary in general
it was not unusual for
people of that background that new
england background with its puritan
antecedents uh to keep diaries it was a
form as a way of maintaining
self-introspection
uh and and uh keeping a a
a a focus on one's own uh inner self
catholic friend of mine many years ago
pointed out that
that this was the equivalent of
confession for protestants uh and what's
unusual about the the adams diary of
course celeste knows is its length and
it's in its detail but uh there were
lots and lots of diaries kept by yankees
in the 18th and early 19th centuries as
part of that tradition producer of this
program here with us maura pierce
director brett betsel and washington
paul brown and maurice haynes they're on
the controls bethesda maryland for our
next call go ahead please
hello bethesda
this is delaware
where in delaware uh newark delaware
welcome go ahead and please turn down
your volume okay thank you i have a
question for the professor it seems that
in talking about the other past
presidents many of them owned slaves um
do you know if john quincy adams if any
of his family-owned slaves and why was
it possible for him to be i guess
prosperous without having owned slaves
neither of the adams's uh
either father or son owned slaves
the slave population of
of new england at that time was very
small
uh the economy the society the uh the
the culture was something that never
really was particularly comfortable with
it some of the most strident
anti-slavery statements that i recall
any atoms ever making
were made by abigail adams they employed
free black servants from time to time
but
at no point did slavery play a
significant part in the
culture or
economy of new england and the has just
followed suit in that direction celeste
walker what does an editor do
of papers like the adam's paper well we
call ourselves documentary editors and
we're not editors in the sense that we
cross anything out what we do is we try
and uh make an accurate transcription of
the documents of the diaries of the
letters write explanati explanatory
footnotes and we publish the volumes
we've published 36 volumes to date what
else can you show us there this morning
what i have here is a
journal of louisa catherine adams john
quincy adams wife
in 1815 when he concluded the treaty of
ghent he went to paris
and
louisa catherine had stayed in russia
with young charles francis adams who was
about eight years old john quincy adams
asked her to
close up the house in russia ship the
books home and come and meet him in
paris this was in january 1815.
she did this she did this essentially by
herself with the help of
the people that
she employed and she came along with in
a carriage across
from saint petersburg to paris in the
middle of the winter essentially
what she did
what she didn't know what john quincy
adams didn't know is
it was
napoleon's comeback she's riding in a
big russian coach
with six horses and she's approaching
paris and she later wrote this all down
i think really for her son and her
grandchildren to write but she writes
that
they're approaching paris and they come
across napoleon's army marching back
the army and
more specifically the camp followers
weren't thinking too kindly of russians
at this time
after napoleon's defeat and so it was
becoming very clear that it was
dangerous for her
in this carriage she showed her passport
to
the soldiers immediately
and she writes at which point the
soldiers shouted
long live the americans vive
les american
asked her to shout back vive napoleon
long live napoleon so she waved her
white handkerchief and every time the
soldiers gave her the sign she yelled
long live napoleon
she the
people came over to her side and she was
able to proceed and meet her husband in
paris without any problems chicago
illinois you're next um first of all i
want to uh thank you um c-span for this
excellent series and once again a very
informative show
my question for the professor is is
earlier reference to the corrupt bargain
related to the election of 1824 i know
there's been some speculation that adams
may have arranged maybe a special deal
with henry clay to gain support of the
the house of representatives and i
understand this really hurt him um going
into his presidency first of all i'd
like to know is there any historical
evidence that this actually happened or
were there perhaps other circumstances
that may have
really
affected the vote
and secondly i was wondering if the
professor could please describe the
relationship between henry clay and john
quincy adams i would seem that clay as a
westerner and adams as a new englander
may have had uh very different political
goals but but i understand that they
eventually became very close allies and
i was wondering how the relationship
might have changed uh between the two um
the two leaders before and after adams's
presidency
thank you let me take the first question
first i i know of no biographer of
andrew jackson uh in the 20th century or
even in the late 19th century
that subscribes to the notion that there
was a uh illicit arrangement between
adams and clay
that resulted in adams's election indeed
i think even martin van buren who was a
protege of andrew jackson of course
succeeded him as president in his
autobiography specifically disclaimed uh
any any belief that that had been the
case but as we tell our students uh in
our history courses in college very
often what people believe to be the case
is more important than what really is
the case
and during uh adam's single term as
president that charge was repeated over
and over and over again and certainly
did contribute although i don't think it
was the deciding factor in his defeat
as for the relationship between adams
and clay you're right as a westerner
clay had different points of view than
adams did
from new england this came out
particularly when they both were in
belgium in 1814 negotiating the end of
the uh
the war of 1812 and henry clay had his
eye on the mississippi and john quincy
adams had his eye on the fisheries off
the coast of newfoundland and there was
a gap in there in their interest there
to say the least and the rivalry the
opposition went on
during adams's role as secretary of
state in which henry clay was a constant
critic particularly of adams's
reluctance to recognize the
independence of the latin american
republics before he thought it was
appropriate to do it but by the time
adams was a candidate for president and
clay was no longer eligible for the
reason that i gave before they had come
around to an accommodation they had one
thing in common and that is that both
adams and clay believed
that the purpose of the federal charter
the federal the constitution the powers
given to congress was an active one to
improve society to build roads to build
canals to sponsor uh educational
projects to build a national university
to create a naval academy and ultimately
things like the smithsonian institution
and because they had that common point
of view and because henry clay was
determined to prevent andrew jackson
from becoming president if he possibly
could they formed this alliance but as a
a quid pro quo arrangement anybody who
knows anything about john quincy adams
integrity would would reject that and as
i said all of the jackson biographers of
the 20th century have also rejected it
there's a lot to visit
here in the massachusetts boston area
about the adams family including their
birthplaces over in quincy massachusetts
both the father and the son
second president united states and the
sixth president united states also the
church where they went to church often
you can see there on the screen it's
only about 20 minutes from downtown
boston to drive over there and uh we
showed the church earlier where the
crypt has been closed at least for the
time being it sounded like uh from our
guest uh that we had on the air here
that the church won't be closed for that
long he gave this impression that maybe
from six to seven weeks he certainly is
hopeful and he needs i guess forty one
thousand dollars that's reverend sheldon
bennett he told us he needed forty one
thousand dollars in order to open the
[ __ ] back up the church is open however
and that's the first parish church right
there on the main street in
quincy massachusetts and of course as we
learned earlier this
massachusetts historical society is open
you can come visit you can read the the
papers here and the transcripts bill
fowler who's the director of the
massachusetts historical society was
with us earlier on your screen right now
is the [ __ ] there's a live picture
of the massachusetts historical society
our call is from boxford mass go ahead
please what's your question your comment
um i believe that um john quincy adam's
white wife louisa was
the daughter of an american merchant who
was doing business in london on the eve
of the revolution
and i was wondering how john quincy
adam's parents felt about his foreign
born wife
and how did that affect john quincy
adams relationship with his parents
are you studying this in school
um oh sort of
and why are you interested in this
oh my younger sister is very interested
in president and we watch this like
every day
and what is your name
allison
what's your last name
um
thank you very much that's an excellent
question uh as the introduction pointed
out uh
louisa catherine adams is the only first
lady up until now at any rate who was
not born in the united states because
however her father was an american
citizen she was an american in terms of
her citizenship
when she first visited the united states
which was not until she was 26 years old
the fact that she was born in london
i don't think particularly bothered john
quincy adams but it did bother his
mother
uh she at one point referred to uh this
was before they were married uh to
louisa as a half blood uh referring to
the the origins that you've mentioned
louisa catherine adams had two problems
uh one was the fact that she because she
was born in england a number of people
thought she was an english woman uh and
had was an alien or an immigrant which
is is not true as i said and the other
problem she had was was her
mother-in-law abigail who was a
formidable personality
and in the initial in the early years
when after she married john quincy adams
and after she came to the united states
there was considerable friction between
the two
in the long run however it turned into
uh not just respect but but affection
and by the time abigail adams died in 18
1818 they were very very close so
the question is very good and and she
was able to overcome both the fact that
she was seen as a foreigner by some
people and the fact that her
mother-in-law never was quite
initially was not happy with the
marriage but later came to accept it
and uh getting a call from a 14 year old
who has a 13 year old sister who's
paying attention to this series it
reminds us that we want to make sure
that teachers in the audience who want
to get involved with our
41 part series can give us a call today
if you're watching at 202-626-4858
that's
202-626-4858 or you can get to our
c-span the classroom
materials through
c-span.org slice
classroom and every week during this
series john wheeler who runs our
education department is finding a
teacher or a student somewhere in the
united states who is involved with a
high school that is named after the
president we're featuring for the week
becky bloom is a fourth grade teacher
it's not just a high school as you'll
see it's also
a grade school
becky bloom is in dallas texas
and she teaches at john quincy adams
elementary school
and she's on the line right now we're
going to ask her what she can tell us
about why the school there in dallas
might be called john quincy adams
are you there becky bloom yes i am here
why do they call your school john quincy
adams well that's an interesting
question i've tried to do a lot of
research on this to see what i could
find out and
i found out that the school was named
john quincy adams in 1954 when our
community pleasant grove was annexed
into the dallas community
but as to why they named it john quincy
adams i have to speculate because i have
not been able to find any
real reasons why
i've spoken with my fourth graders about
this and we've tried to come up with
reasons and
they decided that maybe they
named the school john quincy adams
simply because he was a president during
the same period that the first little
red school house was built in our
community
or
maybe he was friends with stephen f
austin
or maybe because pleasant grove was an
annex community into dallas and he was
against the annexation of texas
when he was a representative
and maybe his name was chosen by a
faction of people that did not want to
be annexed into dallas
what do they what do your kids know
about john quincy adams or what do you
teach them
um well that's uh you know in the past
we have i have taught them
about presidents that um
let's say we're outstanding uh in
february of course we always talk about
george washington and um
abraham lincoln
because that is african-american history
month and abraham lincoln did sign the
emancipation proclamation john quincy
adams had never been
a big discussion but he has this year
since i was contacted by you
and
they know that
he was the sixth president
and they also know that he was accused
of buying votes and probably lost
reelection because of that
and that he was the only president whose
father was president before him
which seemed to interest them since our
governor will probably be running for
president and may become the second
president whose father was president
before him
how long have you been teaching there at
john quincy adams uh this is my
sixth year
where do you come from originally i'm
originally from missouri but i've been
in texas now for 21 years and how many
students do you have there at john
quincy adams elementary school i have
19.
how many does this whole school
teach every day we have 900 and
about 87
mostly hispanic students
thank you very much for joining us thank
you
professor parsons um she talked about
the buying votes at the end of the first
term
why did he get why was he defeated so
significantly when his first term was
she was referring to the alleged corrupt
bargain that we talked about before
i think he was
not reelected partly because of that but
i also think that his
gets back to the george washington
business that he believed that
public office was something that should
come to the individual the individual
does not come to
does not seek it
at one point he referred to what he
called what a friend of his called the
macbeth policy meaning quoting from
shakespeare if chance will have me king
will chance may crown me without my stir
and that's kind of the way he wanted the
presidency to come as it had come to
washington
and so he didn't really uh he did not
campaign
for reelection he didn't even use the
office to uh to create friends through
patronage he believed that if a person
was doing a good job
he should keep the job even though he
might be and in some cases he knew he
was working for andrew jackson
uh there's there's a a moving passage in
one in the diary one of his uh it may
have been his son one of his sons said
in effect i'm paraphrasing why don't you
when you travel through pennsylvania why
don't you stop and
meet with the german uh american
community there and speak to them in
their own language because john quincy
adams uh could speak a number of
languages he's probably the only
president i think that was fluent in
german
and adams wrote in his diary in effect
if i do this i've got to talk to other
groups i'll get tied up in cattle shows
and and and fairs and that's not that's
not what presidents do celeste walker
when you are an associate editor of the
adams papers how many different atoms is
do you papers do you look at
right now where our primary project is
publishing
john quincy adams diary volumes three
and four which take him up through 1800
so basically 1789 to 1800 but i've also
worked on the papers of john adams and
the adams family correspondents and also
the diary of charles francis adams all
right of all the papers you've read and
all the you know the people that you've
gotten to know through the written word
and if you had a couple of hours where
you could either drink tea or walk
through the boston commons with them
which one would you pick
oh that is a hard question
i
would really like to be in quincy before
john adams died and but when john quincy
adams was there
and
knock at the door of the house is one
as different people did just to meet the
presidents
just to see the family just to see
see them at home i think that would be
wonderful celeste walker wants it all
shelburne vermont on the screen is the
adams mansion off to the left there is
the stone library which was built by
charles francis adams go ahead shelburne
vermont you're on the air
yes in the late 1960s i worked for
charles francis adams who died recently
and my wife had a class with george
holman's as you remember the holmans are
direct descendants of the adams and
george holman's always referred to his
classes as gentlemen even though they
included women
and my
and we lived at the time in lexington
right on the green where the war started
and the british soldiers killed in the
first battle were buried in the cemetery
behind our house
but my question relates to
abigail and her influence on her husband
and her son
she had said the time the constitution
was being written remember the ladies
and also that all men would be tyrants
if they could
she clearly felt strongly about women's
suffragette and so forth
is there any evidence in the writings of
john quincy
how he personally felt about the women's
role in
in the polity and
as opposed to what he might have felt
the political realities were
since she was such a forceful woman
did she not have effect upon her husband
and her son concerning the rights of
women
thank you professor parsons
as you probably know
john adams
who was the recipient of the remember
the ladies letter
uh i don't think really took it
seriously
and there was not much progress made
with regard to the status of women
during the latter
20 years of the 18th century when that
letter was was written
as for the impact of abigail adams on
john quincy that's something that i'm
not
completely sure of myself there's no
question that as a mother
she had a great deal of influence as a
woman
i'm not quite sure
john quincy adams was in many respects
of a male chauvinist pig when it came to
the role of women in society with one
exception and that is in again in the
1830s when he uh introduced the
petitions on support of anti-slavery
cases many of them came from women and
he defended over and over again the
right of women to submit petitions to
congress but when it came to giving them
the vote he was opposed to it because he
said you can never tell when wives will
vote against their husbands and cancel
out their vote anything in the diaries
or the works that you've read celeste
walker on this issue
no i don't think john quincy adams
addresses this question but it's very
clear he had high expectations from his
family from his wife
as we saw
tell her to pack up the house come from
russia to paris that wasn't an easy
thing to do
but as far as women and the right to
vote i don't think he ever addressed
that question tucson arizona go ahead
please
hello this is philip eckland my question
is has to do with the political stance
of
john quincy adams i wanted to know if he
had a
fundamentally he stood for something and
followed consistent integrated political
principles
specifically
did he believe
that national unity was more important
than freedom and did he believe that
equality was more important than freedom
thank you
wow
anybody who lives 80 years and spends
most of it in public life is probably
going to have uh evolving positions so
that it's possible to say well at age 75
he contradicted something that he said
when he was 30 years old and i would
answer your question this way i think in
the first half of his life
he believed that national unity and
expansion what would later be called
manifest destiny was more important than
freedom he had no real uh reservations
about the united states expanding into
territory even if it meant
depriving indians of their right to
their own lifestyle or even in his early
years expanding the territory of slavery
but about halfway through at about the
time of his presidency he begins to
reverse his position and in the second
half of his life i would say that he
became more his anti-slavery stance was
more important than his nationalism i
don't know whether that answers your
question entirely but as i said when you
when you're dealing with a career that
long i don't care who the president is
or who the state's person is there's
going to be this ambivalence but my
my my quick analysis of it is the first
half his career he was more nationalist
than he was anti-slavery the second of
his career he was more anti-slavery than
he was nationalism where is the state
university of new york at brockport it's
on the banks of the erie canal about 20
miles
west of the city of rochester a thriving
community of extraordinary students and
professors now the if my
history
i remember right erie canal had
something to do during that period of it
was completed uh during uh during the
the last few miles of it were completed
during adam's administration and in fact
he called attention to it in his uh
first annual message what we now call
the state of the union message he
specifically alluded to
the empire state having used flowery
language had wetted the waters of the
atlantic with the waters of the lake
erie other than george washington uh who
died considering earlier
also there were a lot of presidents
alive up until the time that his father
died in 1826 during his four years
uh during yes uh let's see uh uh with
jefferson and and his father and madison
and monroe were all living uh when he
became president did he know them all oh
yes he uh james madison appointed him
minister to uh to russia and he served
as secretary of state for uh james
monroe and of course he knew jefferson
as a boyhood uh
as a boyhood companion celeste walker
are there any mentions in the diaries of
john quincy adams about all the famous
men and uh and or women that we we've
been talking about
uh he mentions everyone when he's in
paris uh with his father he dines with
benjamin franklin he
walks with thomas jefferson
he this is this was his circle this is
these were the people he grew up with
what kind of a of a writing instrument
did he use for these diaries
he he used the pen um that he would dip
in the ink as you can see it's brown ink
it wasn't until later that
blue ink that i've ever seen blue ink
much later in papers so his entire
diaries
all the diaries were in brown ink
yes or it's a little bit darker
sometimes but it's sep brown rather than
blue what kind of paper
oh it's
thick
very
high rag high cotton content paper that
has lasted very well over 200 plus years
bethany oklahoma good morning good
morning
i
found a poem
that was in the front of a book that was
actually written
by john quincy adams about himself the
poem is entitled
massachusetts
and i would like to read it to you it
consists of about five lines go right
ahead
john quincy adams of quincy
and with the name why should the pen
forbear
the bosom's wishes breathe in fervent
prayer
that years and long succession still may
find
the volumes owner
blessed with peace of mind
with joy and mingle from the cup of woe
with all that braids the wreath of bless
blow
till earth shall yield in friendship and
in love
her glowing gleams to brighten rays
above
and it was interesting to me
that he asked for peace of mind
uh joy and love
in the last years of his life in this
point
is that is that written in the book
itself
in his handwriting it's in his
handwriting the page was torn from the
book
it was written in january the 19th 1837
why are you interested in this car
i collect presidential history and
what you have there is is an example of
what adams was asked to do increasingly
toward the end of the last 10 years of
his life young usually young women but
not always
present him with copies of books and ask
him to write something in it as an
autograph and he sometimes not only
signed it but also wrote a few lines of
verse he's one of two or three
presidents jimmy carter being the most
recent who aspired to poetry
there's mixed reviews on the quality of
his verses but uh that what you have
there is an example of that that
interest that he had celeste walker do
you get many uh
oh high school grade school kids that
come through here for tours and look at
things like the diaries you're working
on
we get quite a bit of interest from
students around the time of the national
history day celebrations
the
society because it's
relatively small with a small staff we
don't have many
public programs for students although
many teachers they make arrangements to
bring their students in for a tour and
we put out items that we think they'll
be interested in do you think people use
this place as much as they should
i think there are many people who may
not know about it and and don't use it
but i do think echoing bill fowler that
if you are working in american history
you almost have to come here for early
american history and it seems to me that
you would
find out about us our microfilm of the
adams papers is located however at
over 90 libraries throughout the country
so somebody can read this at a local
college library let's say or a very
large municipal library somewhere else
what happens if you want to buy all the
microfilm what does it cost for all the
john quincy adams diaries i don't know
what the cost is now university
microfilms markets them for us though
i'm sure they'd be happy to but it's
expensive i would get it's expensive yes
tracy california you're next go ahead
please thank you for taking my call i i
could uh comments and quests and a
question i visited the homes and our
burial sites in 1995 and enjoyed my time
there and i also liked the bookstore
gift shop i thought it was very well
stocked i had a great time over there
in quincy
my question to mr parsons and miss
walker how did adams feel about
president jackson van buren tyler and
polk and did he provide advice to any of
them i'll take my answer on the air
thank you very much
john quincy adams was
one of those people who was sure that
the institution of the presidency and
possibly the entire united states had
gone into decline as a result of the
election of all of the people that you
have mentioned
that didn't prevent him with the
exception of andrew jackson
didn't prevent him from time to time
from offering advice
uh which was sometimes uh followed and
sometimes not i should say that in spite
of the animus that adams had toward van
buren and polk in particular
they always went out of their way to uh
to be nice to him and respect him
because after all he came from in a
sense a different generation and uh he
was always
at ceremonies for example inaugurations
and so forth given a place of honor
which he usually accepted but he uh he
had little use for any of those
presidents because their principles
usually involved
some kind of defense of slavery
and too much emphasis on states rights
whereas we've already established he
came from the nationalist tradition and
as i've said he never uh he never fully
recovered i think from the fact that the
people the second time around didn't
come to him the way they had come to
george washington as i said in
concluding pages of my biography i think
the story of the adams family and that's
both father and son is one of unrequited
love
they love their country passionately but
their country did not love them back
with the same kind of passion that they
had for it and they never really could
quite understand that here's your book
is it still available for people if
they're want to buy it oh yes madison
house published in madison house 19 last
year 1916. madison house pedestrians
madison wisconsin that's correct when
was it when did you write this when did
it what was it off and on over the last
uh 15 to 20 years and when did it come
out it came out this last year 99 just
last year yeah and celeste walker you
have a document that you were showing us
there what is it in front of you
what i have in front of me
one of the questions we get asked more
than anything is how did the papers get
here how did they stay together
and and the real reason for that is that
the family kept the papers together from
generation to generation
willing it to the next generation
so they didn't get scattered among
numerous descendants what we have here
is the deed of gift that john adams
dictated
to john quincy adams where he says
i hereby give to my son john quincy
adams
and then skips down all my manuscript
letter books account books letters
journals and manuscript papers
this is
written in 1818 at the same time where
he wrote his will
interestingly enough
he also in this deed of gift lists a
silver tankard which he presents to john
quincy adams
well the historical society doesn't have
many artifacts but we do have the silver
tanker that's here and interestingly
enough john quincy adams in his will
while he gave his papers to his son he
gave the silver tanker to his
daughter-in-law abigail brooks adams
whom he was very fond of
we have a lot of statistics about
presidents as it relates to john quincy
adams i want to read you and we also
have a camera
in the
foyer
outside here at the massachusetts
historical society so you can see what
it looks like
if you were coming to visit on boylston
street uh john adams is one of 10
presidents to have been defeated seeking
re-election
that's a 10 of 41. the other nine are
john adams
martin van buren grover cleveland
benjamin harrison william hardtaft
herbert hoover gerald ford jimmy carter
and george bush
he's one of the two presidents elected
by the house of representatives along
with thomas jefferson
he's one of four presidents born in
massachusetts along with john adams john
kennedy and george bush
he's one of 15 presidents to have served
in the u.s senate before becoming
president he's the only president to go
on to serve in the u.s house however
andrew johnson went on to the senate
after he was
out of office in
1968. he's one of six presidents to
previously served as secretary of state
along with thomas jefferson james
madison james monroe martin van bjorn
and james buchanan
he's one of four unitarian presidents
along with john adams millard fillmore
and william howard taft
he's one of six presidents who attended
harvard
he was 57 years old when he became
president meaning that he was 61
when he was out of office so for those
20 years
17 of them were in the house
how much time did he spend here in
massachusetts versus washington d.c
you mean out of office or no
i mean how many in those days how much
time would you not spend in the capitol
in those days uh if you had a home in
new england uh you generally avoided
washington in the uh in the summertime
for air conditioning so they spent most
of their summers uh here in in quincy
professor parsons and celeste we go to
knoxville maryland go ahead please
hi there i want to thank c-span for
doing this great series
i had a question about
when john quincy adams was secretary of
state
under the monroe administration
he was involved in one of the first
disarmament deals in the history of the
united states maybe the world was called
it was an agreement with
great britain for disarmament of the
great lakes it was called the rush bago
agreement i think the pronunciation is
right uh anyway uh there was an
interesting question about that uh with
regard to whether why john quincy adams
didn't
have president monroe submit that to the
senate for a formal two-thirds vote as a
treaty
he instead they called it an agreement
and and tried to
do it without going to the senate and i
was wondering if
you folks have any insights into why
adams and monroe chose that route
eventually they did go to the senate
when the senators made a fuss but i was
wondering initially they chose not to
and i'm curious
why that was
i'm not sure
on the details you may know more about
this than i do
this was something that was negotiated
not by adams
but by the acting secretary of the state
uh secretary of state at the time uh
richard rush hence the name i believe at
the time adams was on his way
back to the united states from london to
accept the appointment as secretary of
state and the fact that adams himself
although i'm sure he approved of the uh
the agreement uh was not directly
involved i think that may be part of the
answer beyond that um i'm not i'm not
sure as i say this this may be something
you know more about than i do palm
desert california go ahead please
hello palm desert
yes sir
hello
you're on the air sir please go ahead
yeah
bonjourno just saw a beautiful desert
sunrise here
i'm calling mainly about the boylston
family
and i wondered if you had any comments
regarding
the influence that it might have had is
relationship
from the standpoint of
inheriting the boylston intellect
their social position
and from a yankee standpoint maybe their
money
thank you caller who are the boylstons
uh celeste may have to help me on this
one uh
john adams mother i believe was a
boylston
uh and the boylston name comes up very
frequently thomas boyleston adams was
the name that they gave to their one of
their sons and that was also passed on
uh by uh john quincy and his sons down
there beyond that i'm not sure and there
was a boylston professorship at harvard
for many years i'm not sure whether it's
still there or not but maybe celeste can
help us on this one too anything to add
celeste walker well the wilsons were
cousins and they uh
i'm sure
they inherited the intellect
many boylston's were doctors many were
merchants i
don't know that any money came their way
through the boylston's though sterling
connecticut go ahead please
hello um we have articles my name is
lita and we have several articles of my
great grandmother and her name was
susan pauline adams she was born 1210
1842 and she was a direct descendant of
john quincy
and we're wondering
who how she was related how we would
research this
any ideas celeste walker well there's a
was a book published in 1898 which lists
all the descendants of the original
henry adams that came to this country
it's a book by andrew n adams and it's
called
henry adams of braintree and i think if
you go to your local library they should
be able to get get it for you on
interlibrary loan because it has been
reprinted within the past 20 years or so
i think by the way if people want to
reach you i i understand that tomorrow
because of the marathon here that you're
not going to be open is that correct we
won't be open because it's patriots day
ah not because of the
no the marathon
we won't be here because of the marathon
i can tell you you have a final document
you want to show us on amistad yes i
have uh two things here interesting uh
this is a letter from one of the african
captives
it's uh a letter from kalei and he says
dear friend mr adams i want to write a
letter to you because you love mendy
people and you talk to the great court
he wrote this letter after adams had
agreed to take the case but before he
had appeared before the court he goes on
to say jose ruiz
say we born in havana he tell lie
we stay in havana 10 days and 10 nights
we stay no more we all born in mendy
at this time
the captives had been here about a year
and a half
i don't know if clearly this letter was
dictated i don't know who wrote it
though i don't know if if the captives
learned how to write
by the way we're out of time
once again wrapping this up you've been
here how long i've been here 25 years
what's the best thing about this job for
you
oh the best thing is is sitting there
and reading the manuscripts and reading
something you've never seen before and
probably no one's ever noted down
thanks for doing this for us this
morning
thank you for coming sunday morning
professor parsons what uh what do you
dislike the most about john quincy adams
the great fear that uh if i make a
generalization about him i will have
overlooked something that contradicts it
there's such a massive material
that it's virtually impossible for one
uh human being to say with authority
that they have read everything that's
relevant that john quincy adams ever
said or did
i want to thank the staff of the
massachusetts historical society for
letting us come here on a sunday morning
and also uh the
speaker of the house for letting us put
a camera in statuary hall on a day when
there are a lot of tourists there tina
tate who helped us in the gallery down
there in the house radio television gary
the cable vision systems of boston a big
cable system in this
area surrounding this whole town
and the staff of the adams national
historical park marianne peake
superintendent over there in quincy
and
back home in washington our education
staff is in today ready to take your
calls one more time we'll give you the
telephone number it's 202-626-4858
and cspan.org
classroom
call them now if you're interested in
joining cable in the classroom for all
teachers it's free of charge we will not
bug you in the future with any kind of
solicitation whatsoever
and we thank our viewers who always
bring to this a special spontaneity and
to the young folks who are calling have
a good day
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
next more on the life of the nation's
sixth president john quincy adams in a
moment a look at how he impacted the
founding of the smithsonian institution
in washington dc
this segment's a little under 10 minutes